[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 166 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Madol and i'm here with my
colleague john Foust John how are you
doing today really really good good
haven't been having a lot of fun this
week so really excited to get talking to
our guests today
yeah not too cold in New York I hope
actually it snowed and I was able to
escape the snow that's good awesome so
this week we are talking to Lucia sue
Burton and Kevin Nelson Lucia is a
global developer advocate for sa P and
Kevin is a developer advocate for Google
cloud we're gonna be talking about sa P
Hana
which is very exciting and interesting
and then we'll move on to our question
of the week where we'll be talking about
programmatically searching for links to
an image that sounds cool I've actually
got to mess around with that when I
built out my first project when I joined
Google yes but yeah why don't we get
stuck into our cool things of the week
John when you take it away you get a fun
one this year at GDC we are announcing
six sessions and learning workshop on
monetizing your game most of game
developers when they create their game
if they want to make it completely free
to play but you know earn some income
they'll probably introduce ads into
their game so Google AdMob and Google
Ads will be a GDC and holding these
sessions and mixers and we'll also be at
the Google mixer mark and I believe
we'll be there if you're gonna be a GDC
stop by and see us my next one speaking
of games there is now a new game
developer hub so if you're looking for a
singular place to look at all the stuff
for Google cloud to do with games if you
go to cloud.google.com slash doc slash
games can see a set of quick starts
featured code labs featured products
resources keep an eye on it it's just
started but I expect there'll be lots of
cool things to come still yeah I'm
pretty excited to actually be adding
some things to it hopefully yeah sweet
the next thing we're going to talk about
is cloud BigTable and its announcement
of replication capabilities that are
currently in beta this functionalities
use currently by Google search Google
Maps API and YouTube what this does is
allows us to replicate clusters in
Annie's own at any time and seamlessly
at scale from gigabytes to petabytes so
you would imagine that you know scaling
that high would have some type of
latency but this expansion
allows us to do that with high
performance throughput and low latency
response times this one's a little bit
old so back in February 2010 mention it
previously and I realized that so Kay
native had it 0.4 release back in
February really nice K native now has
support for not just HTTP by also
supporting HB 2 and G RPC it also has
the ability to upgrade an inbound HTTP
connection for WebSockets as well so
there's a lesson new stuff outside of
that also 4k native so make sure to
check out the github repository and see
what's going on and the last cool thing
of the week is being able to build with
the G suite classroom API it allows
developers to access course data program
eclis and it allows them to build deep
integrations within classroom so to
enhance learning and save students and
teachers a lot of time the classroom API
allows developers to integrate
applications within their classroom such
as apps that gamify lessons and
interactive quizzes that way you can
gain the interests of your students I
currently use classrooms so I'm pretty
excited to put my hands in this and see
what kind of cool things I can build out
for my students fantastic
well John why don't we go talk to Lucia
and Kevin and learn all about s ap Hana
sounds good so today on the podcast
we're being joined by Lucia sabaton and
Kevin Nelson Lucia thank you for having
me by the way my name is Lucia Sebastian
I'm a developer advocate at as ap yeah
we love the ACE here and Kevin all right
Kevin Nelson I'm a developer advocate
based down in Los Angeles and I focus on
ecosystem partners like working with s
ap to enable their huge development
community to to learn more about Google
Cloud and today we're going to be
talking about s AP Hana like yeah at a
high level what is this AP Hana I
actually have no idea it's a data and
application platform that has an
in-memory columnar oriented database in
it that was a lot maybe break that down
a little just like a touch well it's a
the platform which we run our s AP
business applications okay
I think one of the key benefits that
Hana provides with this in-memory
database is being able to handle large
enterprise transactions with very right
tight time constraints so you're able to
handle the day-to-day business needs
seeing that you're not gonna go out and
hit discs so you get you get really good
latency yeah you said something
interesting in there too you said it's
both at data and an application layer
yes
so traditionally our ERP applications
for example where customers run their
operations and all of their business
related stuff ran on any database so
when those business applications started
running they were database agnostic and
that was on purpose but with time we
realized that our customers and
businesses they really value their data
and then you also understand that as
Google and we found that we needed to
provide them with a better way of
gaining real-time insights about their
business so for example when when I used
to do consulting one thing that was
pretty usual is for somebody like a CFO
to have to wait for a week before they
could answer the question of how their
business finance is going and we found
that we had to solve that and that was
not something that was acceptable
anymore so we came up with this platform
that being in memory and having columnar
capabilities and having the ability to
run advanced analytics allows this
applications to tap on the really really
fast so for that case this specific
example I was talking about of the week
running report that turned into less
than five minutes to give you an example
of why Hana is so important to to our
applications sounds amazing
I'm curious what can we expect from like
sa P&G CP well we can expect a lot in
terms of what we have been doing with
with Kevin and some other advocates in
your team we have been trying to bring
our communities together our developer
communicators together the developer
community at a CPE is huge and in the
different roles we have people who
really understand the enterprise and
that's what we do we wear leaders in
enterprise applications and at the same
time our customers Net agility and they
need a reliable place to run these
applications so we're trying to do is
bring the Google developers in that
ecosystem together with the enterprise
developers and cross pollinate knowledge
some some reason so which products would
you say that sa P Hannah and GCP
specifically target well we are talking
about always the the business
application so all of our business
Suites like s for Hana which is the the
evolution of the ERP and c4c R M what's
that what's an ERP and a CRM for those
who don't know okay that's a very good
question that that's very natural to me
so so thank you for pointing that out an
ERP system is an enterprise resource
playing that's what what it stands for
and what it does is control of different
areas or business areas in the company
so for example you will have their other
logistics the procurement the finance HR
everything that exists that a company
needs to keep track of in a system in
terms of transactional Indian analytics
that is what one on your piece system
does it keeps track of it and otherwise
you would have to have like Excel
spreadsheets and nobody wants that to
run their business yes that's why you're
laughing just for yourself it makes
sense or if you have a very small
business that maybe make sense but if
you are talking about a global company
you need to really have a system behind
that so what we did with ERP is have the
logics there for all the business areas
in a company let me plug sa P a little
bit here sa P does this type of software
for most of the biggest companies in the
world so they've had to deal with unique
challenges in every single business and
how to manage those resources at vast
vast scale I do not have those facts
super clear about it we have at least 25
different industries and I can talk
about what I implemented myself so I've
been at an auto company I've been a huge
retail company that has supermarkets all
over the world I've been at a company
that does over 80% of the chocolate in
the world which is amazing your
particular favorite place to be exactly
yes that's why I remember it so I've
even implemented a say be an airline so
you also need to keep track of the
maintenance of planes so that is some of
the things that sa P does come back to
like what John was talking about what
unique advantages do people have running
sa PE on Google cloud is there like a
good thing there well yes because
traditionally we were having all this
systems on-premise and our customers are
not interested in doing data center
related stuff and you guys at Google are
great at that your leaders and yeah the
world's moving to a place where in order
to be successful every company has to do
what they're best at and as ap is
fantastic at developing and deploying
these these massive enterprise
applications Google's fantastic at
infrastructure security power management
all the things about keeping Hardware
running I'm making sure that the
application has a platform that can be
fast it can be low latency that can be
successful that can be safe in that way
we have business minding their own
business I always say and they also
there's there's the piece that's not
minor which is being able to scale so if
you have your own data center you cannot
scale but you guys provide a lot of
options for scaling and scaling reliably
and that is very important when you're
running things like Hana Hana is being
an in-memory platform needs a lot of RAM
so it needs proper hardware and we did a
joint effort to certify your hardware so
that's also why it's a good place to run
our applications and specifically on it
awesome I'm a very big hardware guy Ram
SSDs everything yes definitely at the
top of my list for anything that I build
so I have a question focus more about
bigquery an integration with AP Hana yes
that's something that we have been
showcasing a lot so we have this
capability of integrating bigquery in
Hana by you saying smart data adapter
that is something the technology that we
have in Hana that allows us to simply go
and tap and do queries on big queries
huge data sets so we generally we would
go and tap into what would it be
probably cold data for a Hana system and
run the aggregations and whatever we
need to do and in bigquery and then move
it over to Hana to integrated with warm
or hot data yeah this really is a key
capability because one of the
constraints of any memory database is
obviously businesses have more data than
can fit in physical memory so having it
running in Hana in this calmer database
everything is fast low latency but what
do you do with last year's data and the
data that you want to run historical
reports on so once that data is
offloaded into bigquery now you can
integrate that into queries directly
within Hana like it's sitting there but
then gain the benefits of Google's
massive scale for doing these you know
massive petabyte scale queries in a
matter of minutes so provides unique
capability for looking at historical
data and joining data across different
systems that probably segues nicely into
what sort of workloads we run on ASAP
Hana I think you've mentioned analytics
but now we're talking about integrating
bigquery and like there seems like
there's a lot of things that this could
do where do you see it's sweet spot
really being actually what you're
describing is the sweet spot is the
ability to run what some analysts called
trans litical data because the idea
behind Haun is that you not move data
around and that you can run aggregations
on-the-fly and not having to move data
around or persists aggregations and
indices we actually use it to run both
transactional and analytics in that same
appliance so you can do transactional in
analytics by having analytics I mean not
just aggregations as I just said but
also any of the advanced pieces like we
have machine learning we have predictive
algorithms geospatial graph you can even
have a document store on top of Hana in
the same platform so literally you not
need to move data around so that's why
you're asking well there's a lot that
you can do and yes that is exactly the
sweet spot is having a lot of
possibilities out of the same piece of
data nice and I'm actually kind of
curious on the flip side what didn't you
use it for well I wouldn't use that if
you only need a single gape ability
because it sounds like an overkill and
if you're going to run small data sets
because it's also an overkill so the the
smallest unit that we have is 32 gigs of
ram and i have that on my massive
computer that you saw earlier but I'm
I'm writing that on my laptop but I run
that because yesterday for example I was
playing on the plane with some MapReduce
to splayed a huge food data set that I
loaded
you're just keeping transactional or
just doing graph or only doing
geospatial it doesn't make any sense to
have this full-blown database with a lot
of capabilities on top catcha this is a
personal question
why is it that every ta that I meet
actually does queries on large datasets
on food it's always food there's usually
cheese there's wine I've seen clouds
yeah I've seen cloudy clouds it's not
food yeah I couldn't do it with cats but
if I could if I found a data set about
cats I would do it we didn't hook you up
with some people yeah yeah on this later
moment I would I'd point out the CEA's
fingernails here no I know from the
podcast can you see them so maybe you
might want to explain well I I felt that
we've been doing so well with with our
partnership that I wanted to co-brand my
fingernails nice I have the Google
colors and I have not a very successful
attempts here to draw the SVP logo but
that is what this would have been so I
have the SVP logo and the Google colors
yeah yeah I'm enjoying it I think it's
fantastic
maybe we can get a picture for that it's
really interesting like I hear you talk
about sa P Hana and then like you sort
of drop little things and I'm like wait
what was that and what was that - it
sounded almost like you were kind of
giving a very short list of features
that Hana will do like you were talking
about geospatial stuff you're talking
about graph querying can you give us
like a short list of features of type of
stuff that it can handle I guess like
you're saying like you could use it as a
document DB if you really want op of
that you can do text mining in text
analytics okay and there's some
combination then you have the
combination of that we have streaming
analytics like for IOT and that is
something I actually implemented in my
city of birth so you get information
coming from sensors and you can run
predictive and you can run certain
algorithms while the information is
getting pumped into the database as well
so that is also another cool feature
that it has and one thing that people
ask me a lot is if it's an in-memory
database which makes it very fast what
happens to the
if the light goes off and I can assure
you that the data is stored in this okay
so you were saying this is the logically
yes data is stored in this one thing
about the architecture of Hana and why
it was thought this way it's not only
the memory capabilities and the
processing happened in RAM it also
happens in the CPU cache so it's
extremely fast and by being columnar and
combining this architecture you can get
rid of materialization of data or copies
of data inside the database and by that
I also mean indices for example so
they're not as necessary as in a
traditional database and we found in
internal studies that once you might
grade you get rid of 60 to 95% of the
objects in a database because you do not
need the redundancy and so that's that's
another long answer to this capability
but it's one of the reasons why we are
shifting our applications tours on as
well so if I'm a developer and I'm like
this sounds really cool how do I build
on top of s AP Hana do I need to be part
of the s AP ecosystem or can I just pick
a programming language and go at it or
how does that work you can pick up any
programming language and go at it as
long as you can can I prove JDBC or Oh
disease that's like with any other
database we also have an application
layer that is based on Cloud Foundry
so if you want to build microservices
based we officially support free bill
packs then we have a lot of libraries to
connect and tweeny hands dead for Java
JavaScript and Python so that's another
option if you are into it and then it's
just sequel all these capable it is that
I mentioned they're all sequel based so
you do not need to learn a lot and if
you want to deploy it I have to say that
my favorite options we have a lot of
options to deploy Hana specifically on
Express and Express is our free version
even for productive use yes
so up to 32 gigs of ram you can deploy
it and into whatever you want my
favorite option of all the many options
that we have out there to to deploy on
is actually the GCP vm guess it takes
less than 10 minutes to have it up and
running and it's super easy to get
started with your sequel is that market
or is that something else it's a
marketplace so you will find two options
you'll have a say peon Express Edition
and then say bihaan Express Edition with
X's advanced applications excessive ants
a star version of closed foundry that is
enhanced is what I was talking about
before so you have both options but it
will depend on what you want to do if
you want to do Cloud Foundry then go
with the exercise one and then otherwise
you can just use the server only piece
than just the database Lucy you went
kind of quickly over one point I think
is rather important to bring up she
mentioned that she could deploy Hana
Express in about 10 minutes on GCP when
we demonstrate this at technical
conferences and even to internal si P
developers there are audible gasps in
the room being able to deploy Hana in
five or ten minutes is not something
people expect five or ten days would
probably be considered a good thing
normally so say this is something that
is a super important for doing any kind
of dev test applications you know even
at massive scale you can test
applications by spinning up an instance
of Hana a few minutes you can give each
developer their own instance to play
with different aspects that ends up
being a critical way of changing how
companies think about doing application
deployment yes and on top of that one of
the other things that we've been playing
with especially a tech head when Kevin
in the case he joined me there was
deploying Han and kubernetes which is
also super fun and then super easy and
everybody likes it and again it's it's
very easy for somebody to spin up an
instance load data in it and if they
want they can just deploy one again and
it will take zero time I'm guessing then
like by the same token if I want to try
this out locally I can pull down the
container you can pull down the
container yes pending on the operating
system not all the operating system are
supported I personally run it on Ubuntu
like it you can also download a
full-blown virtual machine and then have
it running locally in your laptop funny
thing is you use the word fun several
times in their last couple of statements
I'm interested in what interesting
things that people have been building
with Espeon well there's there's a lot
of even outside the brining the the
business and and this use case is like
the major chocolate maker of the world
that
I find it very fun because we we
establish that I like food but for
example one of the one of my favorite
use cases is the elephants rhinos and
people organization they're a nonprofit
organization in South Africa and they
hooked up drones and some sensors on the
different herds of animals and they are
using that to predict and detect
potential poaching so they reduced the
poaching incidence in the monitored
areas by a hundred percent oh that's
amazing so that's one of my favorite use
cases the other one is a bit more
serious and or sad related so to speak
but it's still happy in the sense that
it's related to cancer so with the
American Society for cancer in ecology
and cancer link they started gathering
of these possible sources of information
related to patients their histories that
treatments the tumors characteristics on
their tumors and they use that to help
doctors establish the best possible
treatments based on other patients
across the globe and right now they are
topping over 1 million records or 1
million histories of different patients
and and that is getting so successful
that doctors are given in their own time
to add imput to that a major database
sounds interesting I actually glanced
over an article I think maybe two days
ago that said that pretty soon machines
will be able to predict strains of
cancer a lot faster than actual doctors
well so that's going to be fun of
amazing so yes it's great I know we had
a sleepy we also have a huge case about
genomics doing the crunching data around
genomics which is pretty hard and I know
that that you guys that Google are doing
something similar so it's it's great
that we could potentially join forces or
that kind of use case yeah we love
collaboration actually speaking of
genomics I know genomics a really large
datasets
how big a dataset can you actually put
in s AP HANA well you technically do not
have
limit because it can scale up and scale
out more so you can make a server bigger
add more RAM or you can make the server
clusters at friends do that server so
you can continue adding data to your
ecosystem of Hana servers as long as
they can scale and if you scaling out I
know it's an in-memory database I know
you were mentioning transactional
support are there any limitations around
that or like what sort of scaling out
strategies can you use with ASAP Hana
well it depends on how you're clustering
or segregating the data okay but one
thing that I should have mentioned is
that Hana does have the ability to
recognize that data and doesn't need to
be in memory as well as oh there's
something called data tearing and you
can choose to have the data that is more
commonly used in memory and the rest
have it like near memory like in desk
for example so that is one thing you not
need to have all of the columns in a
table loaded in memory and actually the
platform itself is going to unload data
that you're not using so you as a
developer do not really need to care
about that one thing you may need to
care about that is data costing latency
because you're pulling data from
different physical notes so you have
network there but it will depend a lot
on the use case and how your partition
on the table you can choose how your
partitions it sounds like it sort of
shards it across the different machines
and does something like that god it got
it got it got it if we wanted to really
get started with SCP Hana what would be
like a getting started guide from both
Kevin and the see if you don't mind me
asking I'll start I open up a cloud
console go right to marketplace you can
download and install in a matter of a
few minutes I say P Hana with the
application environment are ready to go
and start playing yes and I'll do a
shameless plug here if I that's
literally the point of a podcast that is
why you here
they should also request a code gem so
with Kevin and Casey we have been
traveling across the globe and go into
where developers are and showing them
how to deploy on how to connect it to
bigquery how to play with both databases
we also play with cloud functions we
play with kubernetes so we have a lot of
fun I know I say that word a lot but we
do have a lot of fun on being on fun is
the best piece is that the code Jam is
for free all we need is somebody to
request it to contact us and request it
and we'll get there and we'll again have
fun I will make sure to I put contact
details in the show notes yes thank you
it's a free use up to 32 gigabytes for
you just yes yes the the license is
completely for free and you guys
generally offer the trial credits oh
that's right so that makes the entire
experience for free yeah definitely
leveraging those 300 dollars and pretty
credits for any new Google Cloud account
allows people to you know look at the
sort of more production like environment
before they have to make any kind of
serious investment otherwise if you have
room to run it locally the minimum for
the database only is 8 gigs of ram in a
computer it can get a bit slow
especially if you want to add a lot of
theta on food or cats or whatever it is
dogs are probably ducks or dogs I like
dogs yeah I like dogs too but you could
still run it locally or in a VM or a
docker container suite well we're
slightly running out of time but before
we finish up is there anything else you
want to make sure you mention or
shamelessly plug or just do either
you're gonna be at any events or
anything like that do you want people to
be aware of anything along the Minnesota
lines before we finish up today
yes we will be doing more events this
year we will be doing more events even
including some of the piranha stuff so
if you're interested in understanding
what an enterprise developer does or
you're working at a company that has a
CP and you want to know how you can
contribute
you should go into developers dot s AP
comm and we have the events listed there
and we have the co gems that you can
join in in a city and if we're not going
to your city you can request us to
to come to a co job we have some
upcoming code jams for everyone later
this week in Los Angeles we're gonna be
doing two in Germany and Mon Haim and
Munich the week of the 18th and 19th I
believe and then last year Google
represented at the three s AP tech ed
events around the world these are kind
of like next they're you know huge
aggregations five thousand almost seven
thousand people in Las Vegas Barcelona
and Bangalore India will be at those
events in the fall again this year and
look forward to exposing a new
generation of developers to Hana running
on Google cloud anything happening in
next speaking of next well we'll be
there we will have a there will last
year we did a lot of hands-on activities
as well so we had computers there for
people to come and try so yes we will be
there and I always enjoy having
conversations with the audience at
Google nights so really looking forward
to it awesome well Kevin Lucia
thank you so much for joining us my
pockets today hosting is yeah thanks
very much well thank you see you and
Kevin for joining us on the podcast
today and to wrap things up we're gonna
have our question of the week and our
question a week is if I want to program
a Glee search for links to an image that
I have how can I do that I've been aware
of like Google image search for a really
long time but I didn't realize we had an
API that essentially allowed you to do
that so if you're not familiar basically
means if you've got an image so if
you've got you know like a PNG or JPEG
or something like that and you're
thinking to yourself I wonder if
somebody else is hosting this somewhere
on the internet or where all the places
this image is used but you want to do it
programmatically the cloud vision API
has a detecting web entities and pages
API that enables you to basically plug
in the content for that image basically
foreign card it and then it'll scour the
internet and send Rebecca a response
basically giving you URLs to say how
much it matches as well as a score to
think of like how close it believes that
images actually kind of neat I didn't
know it did this
so I'm actually kind of excited about it
you know it's pretty cool and I've seen
it done on a pretty interesting TV show
on MTV called catfish where they where
they actually drag the images Google
search and it actually returns all of
the pages that that image is being used
so I would assume that it's around four
same thing fantastic long as we can get
TV shows in everything is fine John what
do you have to what are you doing you go
anywhere interesting or producing
anything cool that people should know
about
I'll be at GDC next week which is gonna
be pretty exciting cuz it's my very
first GDC oh really
yeah it is my very first time I didn't
realize oh I'm so excited for you okay
cool
we'll also be an X and this is my second
go-around in X so I had a lot of fun and
met a lot of people so I'll be glad to
see a lot of folks and ECG C that'll be
interesting for me I'll be strictly
attending so it should be pretty fun and
vector conf 2019 I will be there as well
we're giving a series of talks to a
bunch of high school students and a lot
of large companies fantastic awesome so
I'll be joining you at a lot of that
Game Developers Conference as you said
next week which I think when this comes
out will be this week just to be
confusing which is fine you and I will
both be a cloud next definitely for
anyone who's listening make sure to
swing by the podcast booth and come say
hi I'm sure but if John and I will be
doing stints in that you'll definitely
be able to find us there and then I'll
also be presenting at East Coast game
conference as well fantastic whoa John
ah it's a delight and a pleasure hanging
out with you as always as always
wonderful and thank you everyone for
listening and we'll see you all next
week see you next week
[Music]